foreign
comes from Kyle in Utah he writes I know
you recommend paying for things with
cash or a debit card but how do you feel
about digital payment options like Apple
pay Zell and venmo it's easy for me to
just pay with my phone but it almost
feels like play money at this point
should I stay with what's convenient but
a little harder for me to track with
digital payment or what's more
cumbersome and takes more time to deal
with with pulling our cash and splitting
everything up feels like I can't win
either way
ah the classic Millennial problem Dave
stuck between a rock and a Digital hard
place here
this is difficult but this is true I've
been seeing these videos where people
feel like when it's digital or it's on a
gift card there's so many ways they
don't feel the pain at purchase and so I
love that he's asking this question
because he's recognizing that he's
self-aware that this is a problem for
him
but he's saying I you know with digital
payments I do see that it's easier to
spend it's even more frictionless I mean
apple pays tagline is cashless made
effortless they know that they'll get
you to spend more if you can just double
tap on your phone and hold it near
reader you don't even need to pull the
card out anymore
so that's pretty wild and I know we're
seeing higher levels of buy now pay
later and all these debt issues but when
it comes to digital payments here's my
take if you are doing a zero-based
budget and you are aware of what you're
spending and you've allocated all that
it's okay if you do Apple pay instead of
pulling out your debit card but what
he's saying is he knows that he's
spending more and he feels it less
yeah and you know the MIT study that's
classic is that when you spend actual
cash
like hundred dollar bills with like you
know president's faces on it and stuff
right when you lay that down on the
table
and the cashier picks it up
and they hand you your item that it
activates the pain centers of your brain
your brain says oh crap
I don't have that money anymore
when you use a digital transaction even
a debit card your brain does not
activate it doesn't it doesn't show that
the pain centers are not activated
meaning that you're not emotionally
registering the fact that you're
spending money consequently
uh you spend more
the less friction there is now all
marketers know this
every one of us that have a web store
anyone of any sophistication anyway we
are constantly measuring anything that
causes you any kind of problem anytime
we make you click one more time we lose
a bunch of you
and you don't close the sale you abandon
the cart
and I have to make it super easy the
easier we make it the more of our stuff
you buy
all of us that have a web store know
that and so the ultimate example of
course is as you said I think the the
newest ultimate example before this it
was Amazon Prime because you can just
you know you just push a little yellow
button that's very the even the color
has been tested we've tested different
colors on submit
on an order and different colors cause
you to buy more oh if it's green button
if it's a red button and yellow and with
different products it's not the same
color even wow sometimes it's a
different color with a different product
but that's how detailed we get into your
how easy are we making it on your
emotions to where you just don't
feel the knife as it goes in right
you know that that's what that's how
marketers are doing it okay this is what
how it really works in the digital world
so Amazon Prime you don't you don't have
to you don't have to enter your card
number you don't have to enter any
shipping information you don't have to
click here to use same billing
information as my shipping information
you don't have to disavow one of your
children you don't have to do anything
you just push a button and crap shows up
on your porch That's the ultimate in low
friction until
the Apple Store now you walk in grab
something walk out walk out
it's almost like shoplifting
but the Apple phone knows you were there
and registers your purchase
you don't even have to go you don't have
to stand in line at the register there
is no registering that anything occurred
there it is
in your brain and so that's the ultimate
in low friction I mean it feels illegal
almost in terms of I'm just walking here
took something and walked out of the
store I expect something to go beeping
and mark up you copped a ride up on his
unicycle and not tackle me you know I
mean I'm I figure something you know
it's just feel doesn't it I mean oh yeah
you know what I'm talking about I did
this at the Amazon store in Seattle they
have one it's a grocery store
convenience store where you just said
Amazon does Apple have one too or is it
just Amazon Apple now has one I thought
I thought there's one of each you just
walk out Amazon has them and Apple has
them both it's amazing how that works
and so yes if this is a problem for you
you said it feels like play money that's
a red flag to me that goes we've got to
figure out how to get a hold of this
before we start moving to these more
frictionless payment options I'll give
you a suggestion we've done this during
Financial Peace University for 30 years
when your first start your new life of
controlling your money make it difficult
only add the convenience after you've
reset your habit patterns
where you've if you've lived on a budget
for 9 or 10 or 20 months successfully
and then you want to add Apple pay back
and I did this for instance when we when
we first started this a long time ago
they didn't have pay at the pump
oh you had to go inside you had to go
inside yeah and um and pay inside now
they would turn it on because in those
days they trusted you you know but you
you know and here's what's interesting
the amount of uproar over gas prices
went down after pay at the pump gas
prices can go to five dollars a gallon
oh people don't think anything about it
because they just stick the card in pump
a gas up well that looked like a lot of
money oh well and drive off but if you
have to walk inside
like you're walking to the Gallows right
it is frightening you know you have to
walk all the way inside and if you were
to put down a hundred dollars to fill up
your car and they gave you no change
because the pump maxed out at 100 and
quit
you would be ready to string up a
politician
wouldn't you I mean the people will be
out with pitchforks and because there's
no because that's a lot of friction the
brain is going hello hello hello this
crap just got expensive hello hello
hello and and there's none of that none
of those alarms are going off in our
nervous system at all when we do
frictionless purchases so start out and
make it difficult I'll give you a even
more pandemic a more uh uh primitive
version of that when you first start
break your food budget into two
categories restaurants and groceries
so you don't accidentally spend your
grocery money at the restaurant
it will make you limit your restaurant
purchases and you'll start realizing
that eighty percent of what you spend at
a restaurant is entertainment only 20 is
actual food and you'll realize that when
you separate them when you put it all in
one food budget then you can rationalize
your butt off and just go out to eat all
the time and go on my food budget I
don't have enough for groceries must be
Biden's fault you know no it's your
fault but separating them gives you
friction in that category and causes you
to realize you're spending so it's a
very important discussion we are in such
a convenience culture and one thing that
could help us get back on track with our
finances is making it more inconvenient
on purpose at least until you get a new
habit pattern I use a debit card at the
pump I don't walk inside but I don't
need to worry about Sharon said last
night she goes or at the lake I was
going to go fill her car up and she goes
well how much is gas over there and I'm
like
how much I don't know I love that
Sharon's concerned I don't know you have
enough money it's okay is she saying hey
go to this other station it's 10 cents
cheap she wants me and I'm like she goes
well I go to Costco at home and I'm
going and how long do you sit in line
she goes well I know what time of day to
go to where there's no line I'm coming
after my own heart this is this is why
you're sharing freaking Ramsay and I'm
not sure she's a legend it's you're
legendary that's how she keeps it I mean
you know I do not I'm not concerned
about gas prices anymore that's not
arrogant I'm not out of touch with the
public I'm just not worried about it
anymore I lived like no one else now
I'll buy gas wherever the flip I want I
don't think anything about it right so I
got the room right so there you go and
that's what you're after but at the end
but in the beginning
every coupon every detail everything
until we got our brains reset
permanently in the common sense Groove